mike tyson is speaking out after footage
surfaces that appears to show him in a
violent confrontation the video which
tmz posted thursday morning allegedly
shows the former heavyweight on board a
plane where he repeatedly punches
another passenger now a rep for tyson
tells e.t unfortunately mr tyson had an
incident on a flight with an aggressive
passenger who began harassing him and
threw a water bottle at him while he was
in a seat this can't go hey i'm just
winging it you can't wing it in life
there's also new details from law
enforcement in a statement to e-t the
san francisco police department confirms
there was a physical altercation and
while they're not confirming tyson's
involvement at this time here's what we
do know wednesday night officers were
dispatched to san francisco
international airport two subjects
believed to be involved in the incident
were detained one of them was treated
for non-life-threatening injuries this
person also remained tight-lipped when
speaking to authorities and refused to
cooperate further with the investigation
in that widely circulated video it's
been sent to the san mateo county
sheriff's office
tyson last spoke to e.t in 2015 while
promoting his documentary anybody on
this planet you could beat him in a fair
fight
so you tell me how that will feed your
ego
he told us he had big plans for his next
chapter movies producing movies
directing movies
owning movies
it's just um
i wish i could really tell you about
these deals we have with it
but when these deals um when the deals
get established um
you guys say whoa mike is doing this
it's really from a business perspective
of entertainment is really
something i never dreamed of doing
something i never thought i was able to
do
but the latest doesn't exactly have
tyson's stamp of approval following news
of a biopic tv series and development at
hulu tyson blasted the project for quote
cultural appropriation meanwhile tyson
has authorized a limited series with
jamie foxx attached to play him
[Music]
you